um yes I'm comfortable with the cause
because I knew exactly what the hell I
was signing up for but I feel like
um like how Pearl was saying earlier
which I'm glad this question came up and
she was like you know a lot of girls
will get into this industry and whining
them playing why is someone taking me
seriously why does no one want to marry
me bro I knew that from the beginning I
only really started seriously dating the
moment I was like I can't see so I
started out in porn a little different
it's definitely more
intense the kind of hate you get only
fans of me is I've seen it be more
accepted but being in mainstream porn
where you open a PornHub and you're on
the ads I didn't bother I did not even
bother there's no way because I knew I'm
not saying I knew I was low value or
whatever you guys like to say high value
low value but I knew that like my dating
was gonna be harder but I feel like a
lot of people in only fans are so damned
delusional being like well I am I am a
traditional woman I am a high back no
we're not sorry we just aren't and
that's okay and you'll attract the
people who are okay with what you do but
yeah people want to complain that they
can't